hay que decir que este restablecimiento
de las relaciones colombia-venezuela que
se realizará de manera
casi inmediata pero progresiva y expreso
estas lo expresó de esta manera porque
buena parte del nivel de expectativa
frente a las realizaciones del gobierno
petro tienen que ver con el pronto
restablecimiento de dos naciones
hermanas dos naciones que mantuvieron
unas fluidas relaciones comerciales dos
naciones que comparten enormes
kilómetros de fronteras y problemas
comunes el problema migratorio el
problema del crimen transnacional el
problema de
esta necesidad de reactivar las
relaciones comerciales que por supuesto
conviene a los dos países como naciones
que durante mucho tiempo estuvieron
unidas estrechamente unidas y con una
relación fluída por supuesto está co
inmediatas pero progresivas en el
sentido de que y si bien el gobierno ya
ha empezado a trabajar no podemos
esperar que de manera inmediata se
restablezca las relaciones va a ser un
trabajo progresivo el gobierno ha dicho
responsable y donde seguramente con ese
paso a paso y esa metodología que se
construyan vamos a ir avanzando en dar
resultados que el gobierno necesita
brindar de manera temprana para enviar
el mensaje a los ciudadanos y a la
comunidad internacional que
efectivamente se está trabajando en el
problema